when you highlight often you really
learn to train your fear like a muscle
sometimes the hype isn't the scariest
part sometimes it's the exposure which
is how much space you can perceive
around you my name is faith Dickey and
I'm a professional slackliner
so slacklining is the umbrella term for
all the different facets of walking on a
flat woven band one of these facets is
highlining which is walking a slackline
high off the ground one of the best ways
to train for highlining is setting up
slack lines over water when the current
is passing underneath you you
automatically start to fall that same
direction and it's almost like you're
not in control of your body and that's
great practice for highlining because in
highlining when you're dealing with all
the fear in adrenaline often times it
feels like you're not in control of your
own body either
Chameli is a town in the Alps of France
and it's one of the places that really
drives me in highlining what's different
about highlighting in the Alps is that
the whole experience is more intense
being that high off the ground you look
at the valley below and the houses are
just tiny specks they look like toys
it's unbelievable one of the high lines
that I walked recently in Xiamen II was
on a guilty MIDI and when we reached the
top it was a totally clear blue sky and
we were surrounded by peaks but during
the process of breaking the clouds
started to roll in it was like an acid
trip walking the line I was out there in
space and exposure trying to balance and
the line was swinging beneath me
meanwhile these huge white clouds were
passing and the line would disappear the
anchor would disappear and then it would
reappear and there was no way to control
it I just had to hang on the beauty of
the mountains is awesome and yet it is a
landscape that demands focus and respect
Alpine highlining is the purest form of
the sport I can think of
what's the highest you've ever thought
that almost in a while when you don't
have a fear of heights it's not really
scary it's like being in the craziest
treehouse that you can possibly imagine
that's Mark Senate he's a professional
rock climber and he's talking about
sleeping in a tent
they're called total edges that's
hanging off the side of a mountain he's
been climbing for over 30 years and his
favorite walls to climb are really
really high alpine big wall climbing is
the pursuit of scaling the biggest left
on planet earth Oh in years they take a
few days to summit so he has to camp out
along the way so I want to know what
does it feel like to sleep in a
portaledge hanging off the side of a
mountain the one thing that's more or
less ever-present in the mountains is
when it can be pretty violent you can
experience hurricane-force winds there's
also this thing that we call the Bronco
ride wind comes in hits a cliff and it
really has nowhere to go except for up
eventually it hits you and your ledge
and it can lift the whole thing up so
you can be suspended and then of course
the lead but slams into the wall you're
just thinking about surviving and that
wasn't the worst of it
the smell in the ledges is not it's not
nice you don't change your clothes you
don't bathe it's wicked scummy but
people love it they continue to climb
and explore do all of this punishment
because there's still that one question
left how does it feel the way it makes
you feel is like a tiny speck of dust
very empowering it really is just like
kind of the most spectacular spot that
you could be on planet earth feeling
cold is physically painful it hurts your
fingers it hurts your feet it hurts your
face
it's also potentially very
life-threatening my focus really is
anything cold so if there is ice or snow
or cold breeze I want to go there but
I've focused mostly on the polar regions
both in the Arctic and Antarctic only 48
people have completed the unsupported
unaided expedition off Pole compared to
Mount Everest where 6,000 people have
summited it's the most difficult
expedition on the planet to a place a
few people understand a lot of what we
see an expedition the Arctic Ocean is
nothing it's like being on the inside of
a ping pong ball basically you can't see
any sort of differentiation from the sky
to the horizon to the snow surface it's
also incredible to look out on a clear
day and see the sheets of ice that are
rafted together like blocks as big as
houses pressured in these amazing
incredible shapes you can't help but
just stop and be amazed
this is my third expedition the North
Pole
the Arctic Ocean is changing very
quickly compared to a lot of other
places science is estimate that the
Arctic Ocean will be ice-free in less
than 50 years in the summertime
unfortunately we find ourselves not
doing these adventures because they're
there anymore but because they might not
be there in the future
our North Pole trip realistically may be
the last of its kind in history and so
it was very important for me to do this
adventure so that people have an idea of
what this place is like right now so
that we can look back and say this is
what we once had everyday whenever I
hear that buzzer it just gets your blood
flowing your heart pumping and you just
take off at a sprint you really don't
know what you're getting into and so you
can see the fire you're jumping out of a
plane that's always and they induce a
little bit of adrenaline
there are a few professions that
captivate us quite like smokejumping and
I'm speaking with a woman who has been
doing it for over a decade
my name is Ramona be Yuka and I am mama
called smokejumper & McCall Idaho she
jumps out of planes and into forest
fires her job is to contain them this is
what a day for a smokejumper is like you
find a twin otter with the door off
we're all wearing earplugs and
everyone's kind of in their own world at
that point and this flight can take up
to a few hours but he becomes clear when
they're close usually you smell that
smoke since that piney wood burning
smell you know that it's go time you get
in the door and that's when you really
gotta focus your heart is pounding and
then they slap you and your shoulder and
I don't even really think about it I
just go out of the plane I try not to
look at the ground or the fire at that
point you're just super focused
and that was just part one now they
fight the fire I've been to so many
forest fires and yeah every jump is
different but it's not a profession for
everyone that adrenaline is something
that that's a big part of keeping me
coming back I do stop and think wow I am
really lucky to be in this job when we
think about volcanoes we imagine these
eruptive hot violent gateways to the
center of the earth and I spoke to a
scientist who spends the night in them
my name is Ken Sims and I'm a professor
of stoked geology at the University of
Wyoming Ken studies among other things
volcanoes and it's for a few reasons but
one in particular you can start to
forecast dis likelihood for another
eruption to get his research data he has
to spend time in them sometimes
overnight so we're talking about what it
feels like to spend the night in an
active volcano
you're in a big crater it's spectacular
it's this is like being in a deep deep
canyon except for now it's circular all
the way around you there's a lava lake
below you and the summit is above you
volcanoes have a particular smell
because they're full of gas those gases
are very so first so they smell I'm
strong and accurate they also have acids
in them and so they're toxic the air can
be dangerous to breathe in you know you
often times are wearing gas masks but
it's pretty hard to sleep with gas masks
and it's noisy it's echoey typically
you'll hear a scene instead of a
campfire there's an active lava lake
looking at a lava lake is just
phenomenal that way it's mesmerizing
there's something about the red warm
glow it's unworldly there's a lot to
distract you from sleep but sim says
none of that matters you don't want to
go to bed I mean this is how the Earth's
surface formed was from volcanoes and if
you're in the moment it's amazing that's
so cool